I love I am obsessed with you
I cannot first of all this no yeah you
know I just felt true to you when it
comes to you safe whoever's watching
this right now you need to know how
great of an interviewer he is like your
body life right now I'm happy to start
with you I feel at home I when they said
Miss Hannah motors coming I limp and
said let me get ready let me buckle up
because and he or she comes through with
this neon look I mean always serving no
snake this time though no snake I'm
actually so happy I for me for the
streamys I was like I want to be
comfortable I've done a lot of looks
that are waist trained snake trained six
inch heels uncomfortable for the vibe
you know some today tonight I'm
comfortable and it's awesome and really
working a still look rich rich but
comfortable you know I'm just going for
a girl in a sweat suit oh yeah very
Billy a little Billy a lady let's not
act like everything I do is inspired by
Billy seriously 100% I love that this
she goes through award shows just like
comfortable it's fire actually polity
yet her so we're still waiting on it was
a team you know I think that I've given
up on defining my worth in anyone's
follow but she does message me the
Swedish ship from time to time and like
she just like she's so great I'm serious
I support her and everything she does
she's body England Miss Hannah you have
grown up and you were just dropping
wisdom left or right not know words
based on fault no I'm not I'll have a
scandal tomorrow there's still so much
more girls to do but I've grown a little
bit which is why I have you really have
I mean looking back of this past year
you made a lot of headlines it's been a
lot of rumors some sure headlines a lot
of false looking back what's been the
wildest thing that you've regret about
yourself and what are you wanting to
leave behind in 2020 oh my goodness I
think everything I've read about myself
has been wild in 2020 I've been pregnant
I've been dead or alive someone's
holding a snapchat outside this is hi
Shannon
I love you but every headlines been
really crazy the only thing I want to
leave behind in 2019 is anything that's
inauthentic to be real I think that it's
very easy to get caught up in the world
of press and maintaining an image and
maintaining this highlight reel that you
know the world expects we all do it on
our Instagram and all that kind of stuff
but 2020 for me is a really big year of
realness and authenticity and just like
being Who I am I got to get back to that
you know is it safe to say you'll be
channeling a lot of that in your music
because I know you've been you've been
hard at work on it girl I actually just
got full-body chills when you said that
because all of my music upcoming is like
straight like balling in the studio like
writing about what's in my soul so that
inducts to everything and I want a lot
of the projects I released in 2020 to be
like stuff people haven't heard me say
stuff that I've been keeping in for like
the entire year just like the real me
you know what I mean yeah does your love
life inspire a lot of that as well 100%
I think love is always going to inspire
so much art you know whether it's you
know going through [ __ ] or being so in
love or whatever but I've just kind of
written about all of it and I'm excited
yeah I'm gonna die wait home you made us
s reliable clean now and Jake is also
working on music to write are you guys
playing things for each other or jaqen
are always playing each other unreleased
music on release everything that's one
thing that I love about our relationship
because it's always like we want each
other's opinions of everything like what
do you genuinely think of this and I've
definitely written a lot of music about
Jake and about this year and all that
kind of stuff so yeah yeah I need you to
really set the we didn't clear the air
say we need to clear the air says
because there's always tea when it comes
to miss Qian mo Jo it's really crazy I
think at this point I like I got enough
see this year I'm trying to avoid it and
it's just following me I'm like running
from it it doesn't the girls want to
know Noah Cyrus too called you you're
her girlfriend
Jake talked to et before saying how he
really supports Noah being a part of the
relationship so what is the true team
what is really going on with Miss Noah
to be real I think that I might have
started the girlfriend stuff with like
some youtube title I just love being
around
no there's something better even before
I knew her that is always like just
inspired me she's so real she's so raw
she liked the way she like turns her
emotions into art and cares about mental
health and like was born into this life
but like turns it into something
beautiful is so inspiring to me and I'd
love to kick it with her and that's
there is no tea like that is the tea on
that I literally just like to spend time
with her and care about her and yeah
everything else just kind of makes it a
mess I don't know and it's cool that the
cyber sisters really vibe with you
though I know Miley sent you a weed
bouquet earlier in the year and now
you're hanging with Noah what do you
think dude those are music inspire you
at all to what those paths ever cross
because they're all kind of killing it
with music
100% Noah and Miley's music are some of
the biggest things that have like
inspired me musically like their their
lyricism their melodies their voices
their authenticity like all of that has
always always inspired me and I you know
Never Say Never at anything know is
inspired a lot of stuff that I've been
working on recently so you never know
it's in story and we do also have a new
show in the works as well right there's
so much to cut well I mean I mean one
new show and another season of my show
but both are I've been working on them
every day I spend pretty much every day
shooting stuff for it's been crazy I
don't think I've slept in like a month
but the upcoming projects I'm dying
again wait sorry the upcoming projects
I've been working on show wise it's
crazy and as I find myself every single
day being like how is this my life it
just doesn't feel real even this I'm
like how this is my life you know yeah
before I let you go I need to see any
update on the on the clothing line as
well because I you know I love the
cancelled merch it's my favorite the
Black Friday sale I was up there I was
buying so what is the T was the latest
fashion makes me so happy for like more
than most things that is something I'm
so passionate about it's the first thing
I look at when I look at people what
they're wearing I love it the first time
I ever met you you styled my merch with
a turtleneck and crazy [ __ ] and I was
like you look fire that's a fire fit I
love clothes so I actually just found
out that the most googled celebrity
outfit on a female of the year was my
Coachella Tomb Raider outfit over like
Beyonce well we're like anyone over any
person like and I started freaking out
because it's like that's what I love
clothing is what
I'm working on so much fashion related
stuff and I know there's gonna be people
that are like a little iffy on it but I
love style and I love expressing myself
through it so I want to create a lot of
stuff that I would wear in 20 funny you
know I'm here for and I will be buying
says Congrats on everything it's you
because I love please do so good to see
you Congrats on everything thank you so
much
[Music]